afternoon
please take your seats I'm still waiting
for some more finance committee members
to come
a few minutes
I'm working on my list
I got to catch some people here while
we're here
trust me
recall a finance committee to order
good morning good afternoon
I thank you all for coming
to learn about the most important vote
you take in your career as a State Rep
remember that we have a special place in
the Constitution all money bills must
originate in the House of
Representatives because we are closest
to the people
so we all get to talk with people we all
get to tell them about what we're doing
and they may be questioning some of your
votes on the budget
so this is my 15th budget
I was proud to be the chair of the
O'Brien budget when I was told to cut
the budget 10 and we managed to do that
but this is another unprecedented budget
one of the guidelines we used called a
tax expender tax expenditure limitations
was to look at
the amount of time since the last budget
look at the inflation over that period
and the population growth over that
period add the two together and that
should be a never exceed number in the
past it's been running three four
percent and we were always under it in
all the budgets and sometimes we cut the
budget to let to less than previous
we've done that at least once by 10
percent as I said
but now
we've never had as much inflation
in the last 40 some years as we have had
now
so when I look at those two figures
what's been the two years inflation
12.7 percent
what's the population increase 1.5
percent added together
14.2 would be some people would use as
tax expenditure limitation
14.2 we're not going that high
but we are going to a record increase
I'm sorry well for me a record increase
but not for some of the previous budgets
why are we doing this because everything
is more expensive
the diesel fuel the gasoline the
groceries and everything that everybody
pays
so
the governor and his executive privilege
negotiated with the employees union
and is giving them in 2004 10 2005 an
additional 2 12 percent
what did we just find out that's about
what the inflation has been that's what
we'd all like to see that we get in
inflation we did those of us on Social
Security get an eight percent year over
year with some reflection
so yes
that's going to be some big increases in
this budget I'm sorry to say I'm not in
favor of them but nevertheless
we're still planned to cut
interest in dividends tax so that it
ends in January 2005 rather than up to
2007. there's enough Revenue coming in
that we can afford that
Plus
this is the closest divided house that
I've ever seen
so we have to get votes on both sides
or we wouldn't pass it
there are people that hate something
about it on both sides there are people
that like something about it on both
sides we're hopeful that there's more
people who like it than dislike it
because
I've never had a budget that I loved
everything in it there were things I
really held my breath and held my nose
before I put him in the budget but
I had to do it to get the votes
there's no other way we're all here no
one wants politics is about
it's never that easy
even when you think everybody's on your
side especially one of the reasons the
Constitution put it here
is if you can please Most of 400 people
are now 399 then you can pass a budget
we've all got to be involved in this
that's why I'm delighted to hear who
answer all your questions we'll do our
best to explain what we have done
and remember in this same house
while we were doing this budget we
passed 50 of the but 50 of the house
bills
that had money in them
when we include all those in the budget
that's another 165 million dollars
but it was voted out of this house so we
are compelled as the finance committee
if all of us voted for something You're
darn well better put it in the budget
otherwise there's going to be an
amendment to add it afterwards anyway
because it was well supported
so there are things in there
that
some of us maybe dislike strongly
but
we've got to keep this state running
if we vote this budget down
then we have no choice we'll be stuck
with what the Senate does they don't
even have to consult us they don't even
have to committee a conference if we
don't have something to meet them with
we have nothing
and some of the things that a lot of
people wanted
are gone possibly
so
what we're going to do is we'll go
through division by division because
that's what we do we have so much to do
on a budget we divided into three
subcommittees division one two and three
and we specialize each of those budgets
in various parts of the budget we are
fortunate to have a lot of returning
members that have remembered things that
were said and things that were done in
previous budgets
so that
when you hear the same song and dance
you might be a little bit resistant
until we remember what they told you two
years before and you found out it was BS
so
the highlights are
it's a balanced budget
that does not rely on new taxes or fees
committee Amendment provides
15.89 billion in total fund
Appropriations we're fortunate the
Appropriations have done well some of it
have happened in this fiscal year and
were able to bring that Surplus forward
for the next two-year budget
committee Amendment provides 6.37
billion in general and education trust
fund don't believe the baloney because
we're trying to align the education
trust fund to its historical and
original purpose
what it has come to be evolved as an
education slush fund and people keep
looking for places to spend more
education funds
the intent of it when I was here in 1999
when we created it I was on the
committee that decided what went into
adequacy and we funded adequacy and we
deliberately kept the money that went
into the to the to the tax the education
trust fund below what was needed for
adequacy because if it exceeded it that
money was couldn't be used anywhere else
so we had to make sure education trust
fund just covered adequacy everything
else special they had meals and the free
and reduced third grade reading building
Aid all came out of general fund always
for over 20 years so these people that
are saying oh you're taking money away
from education is bull
we have increased the money being spent
on education
and we are trying to align the education
trust fund with its historical and
original Roots because we can't put
everything there when we need some of it
in general fund all the sources of it of
not all the sources but the main sources
of the education trust fund of the
business taxes
up to 50 percent of them were going in
to the education trust fund the governor
would have proposed to cut it to 35
percent we took a look at it and cut it
to 22 percent there is still plenty of
money going to adequacy and a few other
things in education that we couldn't
pair it down quite enough so the
education trust fund is in good shape
and we're able to balance the budget a
little better
and
we have eliminated as I said the
interest in dividends taxed on January
1st 2025 two years earlier than
initially scheduled
the committee Amendment appropriates 50
million to accelerate the elimination of
the New Hampshire Retirement Systems
unfunded Actuarial accrued liability
and we also hope to put money into the
rainy day fund
it was hit to a hundred million dollars
in this last biennium because of the
money needed for the sununu Youth Center
and the and the Youth Detention Center
to pay for the lawsuits which are now
ongoing and
of course we don't listen to a lawyer
who says more and more and more but
anyway as 100 million we took out of
rainy day fund but now having to try to
build that back up
we hope at the end of this biennium
it'll go back up to 200 million and if
it everything works out in this next
biennium we might add another 50 million
hopefully if everything works out
so
[Music]
I've got all my paperwork here to help
with any questions you have answered
it's a complicated long thing
so what I'd like to do is is call uh
representative Peter leishman up to
brief us on the book here you turn to
part for division
division one and he's been hired at work
because he has the most departments
to deal with in division one and he will
tell you about that right now
so representative leishman
thank you very much Mr chairman before I
go too much into the presentation from
division one which you'll find on page
six I'd like to thank a few people first
I'd like to recognize Mike and Melissa
with the LBA they're sitting over in the
corner without their expertise and help
I certainly wouldn't be standing up here
[Applause]
then those of on division one that
brought this together as far as division
one representative McGuire who served as
my vice chair stand up Don't Be Afraid
and then next to him representative
cambrells
[Applause]
and another spot below we have
representative evil
[Applause]
so again I direct your attention to page
six and what does division one do well
it's easier to tell you what we don't do
so we don't do anything with the
Department of Health and Human Services
safety Fish and Game Lottery
transportation
and education in the Lottery Commission
so everything else in government that's
we try to handle and I have to say our
group was very bipartisan when I stepped
into this role I've only been on finance
for eight terms unlike a chair behind me
but I thought it might be very
interesting and maybe have become a
difficult task with a split vote but it
was actually the easiest
group of people I've ever worked with so
again I thank you so turning to page six
I'll go through these rather quickly and
if somebody has a specific question if
you want to just raise your hand in the
chair behind me will recognize you I'm
sure
so going to the Department of
Information Technology we established a
Chief privacy officer this was because
of some of the privacy concerns that
have going on within State internet
access
Etc
the department of administrative
Services
there's an important thing here probably
one of the most important things we
discuss within division was the pay
raise for our state employees so there's
over 9 100 state employees that were
based on what we've done in division one
in our full committee supported giving
those employees a 10 increase in 24 in a
two percent increase in 25.
again this is a substantial amount of
money you'll see at the bottom of the
bullet it's about 225 million dollars
going to um
we're going to invest 21 million dollars
into the granite place I think some of
you have heard that we thought it was
more appropriate use some of our Surplus
money instead of leasing the facility to
invest in it by purchasing
uh we also set aside additional funds of
1.2 million dollars
for work and relocation of staff at the
State House Annex which is under
renovation at this point
we also had a significant new ask from
the Department of administrative
Services of 3.6 million dollars that's
the last bullet on page six this is
because of our crumbling infrastructure
I'm sure all of you are aware that we
have many many dozens of buildings many
of which need roofs or other
improvements so that was a new request
that was not in the governor's budget
going to page seven the office of child
advocate we had some additional
Appropriations there about a little more
than two hundred thousand dollars
for travel and additional funding for
training this is a very important agency
that we oversee protecting children so
they were looking for additional money
that the governor did not approve in his
budget
so going to the Department of Revenue
we have funded two new positions there
this will they'll be responsible for
out-of-states audits this will increase
some of our Revenue perhaps as much as
three million dollars
and I'll skip some of these uh probably
more boring but again if anyone has any
questions just sing out
um we're also adding additional funding
for two technical staff
positions through the department of
Information Technology to work with the
Department of Revenue Administration
you'll see at the bottom of the
we're adding 75 million 75
000 for additional replacement for
vehicles again not in the governance
budget
now this the next one the state
treasurer we've heard a lot about this
the affordable housing fund initially
this was a 25 million dollar request
we lowered it to 15 million dollars
back as far as I think it was around
March 12th we were exceeding the
position where we should be by about 145
million dollars so the division had to
find something that cut all it cuts are
difficult but this is one of the areas
we looked at and we removed as you can
see
10 million dollars from that line
perhaps that will be restored at some
point we kept the program in place uh
initially all the funding for this
particular item was federal funds so
this is a new general fund appropriation
so the board of tax and land appeals a
bottom of page seven
we're looking to upgrade their database
this is again an additional request that
wasn't initially seen I believe in the
governor's budget
so going to page eight
now this is a very dealing with a New
Hampshire retirement system the division
spent an awful lot of time
on this particular area I want to
personally thank representative Carol
McGuire that the chair of Edna Carol was
very close with us and worked very
tightly with us during this process we
had a representative Pearson
involved representative goalie and
representative Jackie groda so this is a
very bipartisan effort and the first one
you have here with House Bill 436 came
out of the house with a strong vote of
282 to 80 and as you heard the chairman
say earlier we were given bills to fund
and we made every attempt to fund them
either at a portion of the request or
their full amount
so we did fund if you will I I like to
call this as a a fairness fairness issue
a decision for some of you that are
familiar familiar with this back in 2010
2011 there was some rollbacks on
benefits to employees it had not
invested we've reestablished those
earlier Provisions that were rolled back
to bring them current where they should
be so that was a very good decision I
Believe by our group
again this will be totally funded with
State funds it's about 25 million
dollars a year
and this became
an interesting working session at the
fundus we repealed the repeal of the
communications tax which is 28 almost 29
million dollars a year so we repealed
that which gave us an additional 40
million dollars to offset the cost of
these retirement changes now we also
agreed to pick up the municipal shares
as well so there's no Municipal impact
there was some current concern by the
municipal Association that there'll be
some pushback for them to pay for this
but there is none
we also changed a bill was it house bill
50 representative McGuire
yes
that initially there was going to be a
7.5 percent payback to towns towards
their retirement cost we thought it was
more appropriate to put that money
towards the unfunded liability of 50
million dollars so I thought that was a
very good move and then finally with
retirement
we had a group two
cost of living adjustment this will
affect about 3 700 retirees
um we thought that and it was just for
one year the initial bill I believe that
was brought forward by representative
Broody for about 10 years but we reduced
it to a one-time maximum payment of
three thousand dollars
so another issue going to the office of
professional licensure and certification
this required a great deal of work I
think many of you have heard from
Foresters soil scientists Landscape
Architects and many others how upset
they were about these changes without
the policy committee e-dna really having
a first crack at it so we were as you
can see removed about
249 sections replacing
several back and I'd actually like to
represent or recognize representative
McGuire Deanne McGuire who works so
closely on this and came up with some
good compromise and do you like to speak
at all to that yeah just briefly
um we basically left in only things that
are very minor license changes
um it eliminated the Hawkers and
pavelers license the itinerant vendor's
license
and the athlete agent's license and and
it did some cleanup because we're in
general we're moving to
a setup where the the administration of
licenses is done by a professional set
of Staff called the oplc office of
professional licensure and
um so the boards themselves will be
dealing with their technical aspects you
know what kind of EDU education what
kind of testing that sort of stuff but
all the administrative work of
processing applications taking fees
doing adjudication will be done by
professional staff and so we left in
some of the cleanup sort of stuff
related to that none of what's in there
I don't believe we received any
complaints about or nearly none so so
all the controversial thing about
certain licenses being combined or
eliminated and so on that's all going to
be for future legislation
thank you
so turning the page to page nine the
judicial branch
we included basically we supported the
judicial branch again this is a branch
of government and in all my terms on
finance we've generally
agreed with most if not all of their
requests
um as you'll see here we approve seven
new circuit court judges and one
Superior Court judge and the one
Superior Court Judge came from
representative Lynn's bill which is
House Bill 347 that was passed by the
house providing an additional Superior
Court judge that would be primarily
focusing on planning zoning land use
issues
so moving to the Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services
you can see that we did provide some
more General funds there but it also
helps leverage as much as 200 million
dollars in federal funds so this area
they take care of our veterans cemetery
maintain facilities throughout the state
for emergency issues
and going down to the next bullet we
also included there's a house bill 330
some incentives to try to attract former
and new members to the National Guard
going to the Department of Agriculture
markets and food
we've added a position to work with the
soil conservation committee
be going on to page 10. we've included
language from House Bill 230
to develop a uh an electronic licensing
system this system dates back to
I don't know we were told almost the
19th century but so we're trying to get
the Department of Agriculture back on a
firm footing as far as their electronic
monitoring and tracking this was another
bill that came to us from the Edna
committee which I'm sorry the
environment and agriculture committee on
a unanimous vote
going to the Department of Justice we
heard that elderly fraud abuse is
rampant in the state it's going up more
and more
we added another fraud investigating
attorney to this office this was an
additional request from the Department
of Justice to try to deal with the ever
increasing problems of elderly Fraud and
Abuse
all of you have heard about some of the
issues around the youth development
Center in Manchester and elsewhere we've
added additional funds to help the
Department of Justice deal with the
increased investigation work required to
deal with that issue
going down to the bottom of Justice
adding additional victim witness
specialist position again to help
with the anticipated increase from
Advocate workloads with the elderly of
Fraud Unit
so the Liquor Commission again Liquor
Commission is primarily funded with
liquor revenues and not General funds
very rarely their General funds find
their way in that direction but we did
approve some of the liquor commission's
requests for the updated Community
computer system the next-gen sales
system and funding additional PC
software and Hardware to help their
stores operate there's 66 stores operate
more efficient efficiently
going to page 11
again another incentive program trying
to keep our employees with us so we
added language giving the Liquor
Commission authority to enact an
incentive program to try to keep their
employees and attract employees
the department of energy we've left that
fairly untouched except we did give the
Office of Consumer Advocate authority to
transfer up to 75 thousand dollars for
litigation and contract Consultants
you'll see a large
section dedicated to the Department of
Corrections we fully funded the
Department of Corrections requests and
you'll see that we added some additional
things like replacement of computers
some upgrading technology infrastructure
we also gave them further authorities to
transfer my uh funds should they be
necessary in that transfer would require
the approval of the joint legislative
fiscal committee
okay going to page 12.
I'm surprised representative cordelli
hasn't had a question I was just waiting
for one of yours but
so going to the judicial Council
we did what often people referred to as
truth and budgeting
oftentimes we've let this we haven't
fully funded the judicial Council
because they're another agency that can
come to fiscal if they need additional
help in funding their operation we fully
funded their requests so hopefully they
won't need to come to fiscal but again
we fully funded their requests
going to the Department of Business and
economic Affairs this was another area
that some of you have expressed concern
about this was invest New Hampshire we
did modify this a little bit making
allowing municipalities to seek such
funding for construction or towards
Workforce housing the original request
was 30 million dollars this was funded
all with federal funds in the past this
is a new general fund item
but we kept as you can see here 15
million dollars in that line versus the
authority and as I pointed out earlier
we had to cut somewhere and it was
difficult to meet all these additional
asks and fund all the programs to a
hundred percent so we did take some
money here
that was in the governor's budget
so the Department of Natural and
cultural resources below that there was
a request from the State library due to
the condition of their facilities trying
to protect their artifacts and books
they asked for an additional one million
dollars we granted their request
and below that you'll see the there was
a request for five hundred thousand
dollars to establish the Christa
McAuliffe Memorial in a committee to
raise funds we reduced that amount to
one hundred thousand dollars and again
with the language we adopted it prevents
nobody from providing gifts or other
matching money to help that get off the
ground
so going over to page 13.
this is something we often see the very
first bullet fully funding the
Department of Agriculture I must be
getting tired I almost said agriculture
but uh so this is the Department of
Environmental Services and that's a 27
million dollar Grant to fund ongoing
Municipal Water Pollution projects some
of the folks in finance have referred to
this as Buco bucks in the past because
representative Buco has been behind this
effort for the better part of a decade
we also provided additional funding to
the Department of a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars we have two landfills
in the State uh and there's nobody
maintaining them they've either gone
bankrupt the owners or whatever but the
state still has an obligation to keep an
eye on those landfills and to monitor
their leachate
uh the next bullet down a significant
amount of money 2.6 million to the
Winnipesaukee River Basin program these
are funds raised by this district there
are 10 communities in the Lake District
they have a wastewater treatment plant
that the state runs but they require us
to approve any of their programs even
though it is money coming from the 10
communities and we did approve the
Department's request for that amount of
money to upgrade and take care of some
maintenance issues at that wastewater
treatment plant which I believe is in
Franklin
[Music]
going down to the next bullet this was
another I believe there was a house
request out there though I didn't note
this on my but PCB assistance fund
this again was something that the
department was looking to
fund as far as investigating and
Remediation of any pcbs in the state
now we have House Bill 300
and it's an inside joke among the
division members that this member was
the only one that got everything she
wanted
so uh
this I don't know if representative evil
would like to speak to this
representative evil has been working in
issues of solid waste and food waste and
try to reduce the state's
Solid Waste Disposal volumes and the
division after a long presentation and a
lot of work by representative evil
supported House Bill 300 which came out
of the environment and agriculture
committee unanimous
and going on to House Bill
this was an appropriation a new
appropriation of two million dollars to
help fund the management fund and also
they created a new position to try to
again limit what we're putting in our
landfills and representative evil I
you know if you did a lot of work on
this if you'd like to say anything more
yeah sure thank you very much and thanks
to the division
um
I guess what I would
spread an awful lot about landfill
citing and it's certainly a
controversial issue this is sort of the
other side of the coin where we've been
working really hard
um
through various initiatives with the Des
and others to try to decrease the amount
of waste that's going into the landfills
to preserve our capacity
the food waste issue seemed like a
really good place to start because 25
percent of what goes into our landfills
and weight is food waste so we thought
we'd start small and and hopefully help
infrastructure to receive the food ways
to develop in the state so we can do
better and then the second initiative is
funding the solid waste management fund
and that is a loan and Grant fund for
municipalities and businesses to try to
incentivize the development of more
infrastructure for for diversion of
waste in general and for the first
couple of years food waste in particular
I went to a selectman's meeting in my
district last night and they were
thrilled to hear that this may be coming
because is they have a lot of things
they want to do with their transfer
station so thank you again
thank you representative evil oh there's
a question
[Music]
representative Harrington
you can use one of the mics down there
on the table
HB 300 was retained in committee why
don't we let the normal process go up
for the bill rather than stick it into
the budget along with a zillion other
things
I don't recall that situation but was
anybody I don't represent McGuire just
just in general when when there's
Financial aspects to a bill when when we
send us a bill that spends money we have
to account for it so the way we account
for it is we either we put it in the
budget and then we match it against
revenue and so and sometimes we don't
fully fund it or we change the funding a
little bit or whatever but but by we
can't really very easily just pass
spending bills outside of the budget
because then our our finances are not
balanced I think representative
Harrington said he thought I was
retained in committee right well that's
what I just looked on the internet it
says HP 300 was retained in committee so
if it was retained yes so we're not
going to spend any money so why do we
have to stick it in the budget now why
don't the committee process come out
with it and see what we'll do next year
no when we put it as part of House Bill
2 then we retain it right so that it's
it's not in two places at once yeah I
believe representative Harrington it
came out of the environment and
agriculture committee with the unanimous
vote and passed and then we will retain
it in our division if we're going to act
or fund it or maybe we need in finance
right exactly right that clarifies my
question thank you
all right so moving on
down to the last or almost last bullet
point we have pfas we work with a
representative two from Merrimack where
this has been a significant problem and
we changed the
Loan Fund to a response fund so to act
more quickly and try to deal with pfas
contamination there was 25 million
dollars put in there in the last budget
there's about 12 million dollars left we
did not add any additional money but we
did change some of the language
then going down to the last bullet house
built 276
cyanobacteria so I didn't know what that
was but that's Lake plumes if any of you
know algae plumes that you may see in
the ocean or lakes so
we did include some uh
funding there there's a real problem we
got a lot of support
for that particular program from a
number of different Lake Associations in
the state where plumes are becoming an
annual problem and affecting tourism in
a representative McGuire wants to add
something
yeah
so then going to oh you want to speak on
this one or
so going to page 14 just a couple of
little bullet points again about what I
just mentioned on the
cyanobacteria mitigation program so
no questions
I
there is something I'd like to add and
maybe I'll jinx myself but in all the
budgets that those of us that have been
on finance for a long time have a scene
we get inundated with letters phone
calls emails about the horrible things
in the budget
I think most of us average just a couple
every day when this particular site I
think that spoke well for the
bipartisanship that existed and again I
thank my colleagues on division one for
making it quite an easy process and
representative Maguire guess would like
to have a word or two
representative Magoo for a question
can you come to a mic
rophone
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question was there a language about
another bacteria right at the end of
myobacteria or something
in this in the cyanobacteria clause
uh right at the end
did you add included a different
bacteria eligible for that I don't
recall that we could get that answer to
you it's something that doesn't maybe
does anyone remember
it was I don't know whether it was a
typo or whether you added another
uh something else eligible for those
same loans
I don't know if we would call but we
could check on that for you I don't
think we made any changes to the bill as
as passed by the house
okay thank you Mr chairman except in the
financial area right at least in
myobacteria or something like that
all right thank you Mr chairman so I
just wanted to admit
two big themes of this section of the
budget
one is that
we're state government is having a hard
time hiring we are we are
um we're short-handed just like you know
every other employer is but but in
general State Employers in state
government regardless of department they
have a lot of positions available and
nobody to fill them so we did two things
about that in this division number one
is the pay raise right so the pay raise
should help us fill some of these
unfunded positions the other is
technology we essentially acceded to
almost every request for new computer
systems there's there's new computer
systems going on in liquor
d-a-s-d-r-a and others Department of
Agriculture all of that should help them
with productivity and and help them
overcome I'm not having enough people
and the second theme Here is in our our
biggest department is the Department of
Corrections and they're also the in the
most Dire Straits as far as hiring goes
they have right now only about half as
many Corrections Officers as they need
to run our prisons the the officers we
have are working 60 plus 65 hours a week
they're required to do that kind of
overtime in addition to that parole
officers are coming in and working in
the prisons several shifts a week
National Guard members are working in
the prison and so on it's a very
difficult situation and so in general we
gave the department of corrections as
much support as we could but with one
exception the governor had in the budget
40 million dollars to start construction
of a new Men's prison there's also 10
million dollars for design but 40
million for construction it's estimated
that the construction of a new Men's
prison would be a 400 million dollar
item very expensive and so we were not
we took out the 40 million because we're
not willing to fund a design until we
know what it is right there was some
criticism over the design of the women's
prison and so we didn't want that
situation to happen again so we gave
them support for operations but not for
new construction
thank you
will now recognize chairman of division
two represent emmericht to brief on The
Division II budget
thank you Mr chair
I'm going to start out by revisiting the
educational trust fund
because there's a lot of emails coming
in about
it's been eliminated it has not been
eliminated it has been redefined as to
what it was designed for
initially as as the chair said it was
set up to solve a legal problem so we
had a fund and the court was happy
several feeders fed cash into that trust
fund by in the RSA the lottery is the
only one specified but a lot of other
income was bled into that trust fund
the Catch-22 of the trust fund is it
could only be spent spent on education
so we had this fund this building and
the only thing it could be spent on was
education
all was well and good
when I first went on finance about nine
years ago
there were 220 000 students
in New Hampshire
today the estimate is between 155 and
160 000.
so over nine years you can see that's a
lot
however the con those contributing to
the trust fund continue to contribute to
the trust fund here comes the money here
comes the money here comes the money but
there's fewer and fewer students
so there's less and less adequacy to go
to those students so what happens to the
money
it stays in the trust fund what can you
spend it on education only
well about 2011 it was a tough budget
year
and so the
the
trust fund
started looking pretty good because it
had 150 180 million dollars
only we were spending for building Aid
uh 50 million dollars 40 million dollars
out of general fund
and somebody said hey why don't we put
the building Aid in the trust fund voila
problem solved
this has gone on now for several years
and so the trust fund has about 14 or 15
items that it regularly pays for
13 12 or 13 of which used to be paid out
of General funds
well the chairman decided we got to get
it back like it was because as he
indicated earlier it had become the
education plus fund
so there was a
Amendment passed that kind of reordered
things and took some things out of the
trust fund put them back in general
funds
everything got paid for everything I
mean it didn't take anything from
anybody it just kind of redefined what
the trust fund is all about
now the biggest the purpose of the trust
fund was adequacy and if you go to page
you'll see that we actually increase the
governor's budget
and we went along with it increased uh
adequacy payments by 158 million
so we're well over a billion dollars
right now in education support
so nobody got hurt
we're doing fine we just did some
accounting adjustments
the other thing
is the the charter schools got fully
funded
building Aid everybody hears about
building Aid and we always hear about
the tail oh we got to paint the tail
well what the tale is is well 15 years
ago 20 years ago give or take
when the state was helping local
school districts build buildings it
participated in the debt
so the state every year participated in
a little bit of debt here a little bit
of debt there and pretty soon the state
had a lot of debt we're participating in
over 20 25 year period
that's the tail that's what we're paying
off right now
approximately 50 million dollars a year
that goes into building Aid
about half right now pays for the tail
next buying them it'll be 20 of it will
be the tail and not 25 so the tail is
slowly getting paid off
but as of today there are 17
school districts applying for building
Aid
of those using the new system we don't
we're not doing the old system we'll
record a little bit of debt for a long
time the new system the state pays
a percentage but it pays it up front in
two tranches
so we can't have so many schools we're
helping because we're giving the school
districts more money up front
so they have less debt over their life
of their note and we get out of out of
their note business
of the 17 that that are on the list so
we are going to get funded this year as
I said
hopefully uh if we can find more money
for building a we'd love to help
more building aid but right now as you
see it's approximately 100 million
dollars over the biennium
oh you know if I didn't I didn't think
my my oh my goodness
I got too busy in the business of the
business here let me thank our LBA
Mickey Lonergan
he's my Jiminy Cricket
I had these notes at the bottom of the
page and I'm thinking oh my gosh
my vice chair Joe Petrie it's Joe
representative Heath
representative Bean
representative
okay
moving right along
I'm just trying to think
on page 16 you'll see an item that looks
like it should be part of hb25 the
capital budget
and that's the Sugar River Valley
Regional Technical Center typically the
technical centers two were done at per
biennium
however sometime this particular
biennium this one didn't make the list
so that that is being supported by uh
the 20 the current Surplus
the community college system
uh I was very impressed by the community
college system and what they do
if you don't know what they do you ought
to go online and look at some of the
things and get involved in one of the
one of the great programs they have is
called fast start
and that is high school kids can start
taking college courses while they're
still in high school
and
the high school credit for it at high
school and they also got credit for it
as call as college credits uh
quite a few students are participating
in this
and one of the things that I learned
that was stunning to me is you can go to
the New Hampshire community college
system for two years and become a
registered nurse
you don't have to go for four years you
can go for two years and be an RN
I was stunned wow what a career
opportunity in two years
you got to advertise that folks you got
to get the word out
the
um
well we continue to fund the the promise
program for those eligible for Pell
Grants
uh eight hundred thousand buying for
math learning
Community program
I'm not going to I'm not going to read
to you I'm trying to think of it a lot
of this was very interesting and I could
spend all day talking about how
interesting it was but it's not Finance
um the the university system
the new Chancellor a very pleasant
gentleman
and our old State Treasurer who's now
the CFO that make quite a team I can
tell you that
one of the items that has some
controversy around it is the six million
dollars to support the re
vampire updating of the Whittemore
Center Arena
as you can see it's spelled out this is
actually a 30 million dollar project
they came to the to the state to say we
need to show our alumni that you support
us
and originally they asked for 8 million
after we had a little conversation they
decided 6 million was sufficient to get
the participation of the alumni and the
uh other donors
so we had some very dramatic
uh demonstration visual demonstrations
of what other schools look like compared
to our state school and it was it was
quite striking so we did support the Six
Million Dollars
and we're almost back where we were back
in 2010 of uh 200 million dollars for
the biennium we're very close
Department of Transportation
cities and towns are going to get their
block grants
of 12 percent
High the highway betterment fund is is
funded
um
I'm trying to think
I got to say the Department of
Transportation at that particular time
and the budgeting process was plowing
snow
and so their their minds were otherwise
diverted because that that's a big
expense to them
so
nothing jumps off the page as far as the
Department of Transportation goes
the Department of Safety
one of the interesting things which was
mentioned earlier is they they have a
staffing problem
they're running about 15 to 20 percent
fewer officers
and the primary reason is municipalities
are very willing to pay more
so we're Hiring Our Own State Police
into our municipalities and sogo's life
in the big city
uh
three additional instructors paid for
the fire fund
and we also they're going to get 52 new
state police cars exciting stuff
Fish and Game
we have we had to kick in a little bit
for fish and game because their revenues
are going down covid is over
during covid their revenues shot through
the roof
because everybody was outside fishing
and hunting
now the revenues are starting to drop a
little bit because
we don't have to go outside anymore
Lottery Commission is self-funding they
are adding a
customer database system that comes out
of their expenses police standards and
training
is still supported as they're doing the
uh
accreditation program around the state
so with that
if anybody has any questions you can ask
Ken
thank you Mr chair
thank you
chairman Emory
questions on the areas that division two
just briefed on
wave your hand or stand up so I can see
who wants to ask
represent Harrington
I always have trouble getting through
all these zillions of pages of stuff
here so I think I know the answer but I
want to make sure the Powder Mill Fish
Hatchery New Durham is funded so it'll
meet its new EPA requirement by the end
of 2025. yes thank you
any questions further on on division two
hey I can't talk anymore
yes if you think this is boring imagine
six weeks of staring at this stuff over
here
representative chairman Jess Edwards for
division three briefing which is all
about Health and Human Services
uh so thank you Mr chair uh always a
pleasure to step up with the
introduction that this is really going
to be boring uh so I'll I'll start by
trying to paint kind of the Strategic
situation that we find ourselves in as a
state and therefore is uh division three
and in support of the Appropriations
needed for the Department of Health and
Human Services and and through the
Medicaid and other payer efforts uh to
the rest of the state to our entire
provider community
um we we started with the idea that
the Medicaid and other reimbursement
rates are just generally too low that if
you look at the last 10 years of trend
they have they have been a little less
each year than the overall rate of
inflation so when you take that
disparity over a 10-year period we've
created quite a gap between what
Medicaid reimburses which is much less
than Medicare much less than the
commercial payers and and what the state
was willing to pay so the governor gave
us a wonderful opportunity he and his
budget presentations he said it in my
budget I'm going to give you a 3.1
percent rate increase when the demand is
clearly more at the 15 percent rate
level and he said to us that we are free
to try to solve the problem
so we we did in this budget take a big
bite out of that 15 percent ask and
we're delivering about 11 percent and we
do this knowing that money is not going
to solve this problem not entirely
we have a severe Workforce shortage
there are going to be areas in the
system that we could
have really strong Rich reimbursement
rates and probably still end up with
under capacity because we just don't
have the human talent to plug into these
positions so on one hand we have low
rates on the other hand we have low
numbers of personnel and what we've been
asked to do is division three and I
think we did a fairly good job of it is
to navigate
now we could kind of optimize how we
deployed the resources to sort of
minimize the pain to the state
this navigation would not have been
possible without Mr Ripple of the LBA
being there every day every night every
weekend willing to give me advice and to
support everyone on the on the committee
that that had questions or requests and
and and to the committee members my vice
chair
representative Mooney who kept me in
Lifesavers the whole time to keep a
smile on my face during the meetings and
others and then representative erf who
uh whose experience this is his third
term in a division three uh his number
crunching is vital and then
representative Hull he was here earlier
uh whole is a great one for continuously
pushing us to rethink what we've been
doing
our colleagues
representative walner nordgren tolerski
and Stringham could not be here today I
think
what they may be doing is preparing an
alternative view to how we could deploy
these resources so what I'm going to
tell you is the position that came out
of the finance committee it came out of
the finance committee on unfortunately
what I would consider to be a two two
partisan of a vote and so on Thursday I
you're gonna you're gonna hear a lot of
debate back and forth I'm this is one
view of what you're going to hear and
and I hope you pay attention on Thursday
because there's going to be a lot of
important decisions to make so to start
with the Medicaid reimbursement rate we
took the governor's 3.1 percent the
hospital said that they would forego
their share of it if we gave that money
to other providers because their biggest
issue is they are stuck in what we call
an ER boarding situation
raise your hand if you've heard of the
ER boarding situation please I just want
to I don't want to dumb this down too
much but it's really important for
people to know
what what has happened is that we have
patients that go to the ER that didn't
get care to begin with in their
community that they could have gotten
they show up at an ER when they're at
the emergency room er
um they get diagnosed as being a danger
to themselves or to others so they are
involuntarily
capped
in the ER getting
[Music]
holding down a bed holding down staff
attention but being in a
non-reimbursable status because the
hospital can't give them the care that
they require so the so the hospitals are
just basically warehousing these people
it's just barbaric this is not the way a
great nation treats its patients it's
not a way a great state treats its
patients the ERS know this they want to
discharge these people but they have no
capacity
in the community to discharge patients
into so our priority with the the
targeted rate increases above the 3.1
percent the governor allocated was to
try to solve first the problem of giving
the capacity the ERS needed so that
patients could could move through the
the clinical workflow and then after
trying to address that as much as we had
the resources for we want to the front
end and tried to address some of the
issues with making sure that there are
some Community Care Resources in advance
of the need so that they don't go to the
ER in the first place but this problem
of housing people in the emergency room
is is should truly be unacceptable to
all of us and unfortunately there's not
an optimization formula to tell us
exactly how much money we should be
putting into this so so we've taken and
given it our best shot
we uh we we started with the 12 million
for the 3.1 percent we added another 70
million uh in general funds all of that
gets matched by federal Medicaid money
so it's the impact is is is it like at
least double those numbers on our health
care System
um as a result because we gave different
amounts to different targets in general
it feels like in about an 11
increase in Medicaid rate hikes for the
non-hospital providers
so that's substantial but they had asked
for 15 percent and probably could have
Justified it we had asked the governor
starting back in August or so early in
the budget process to identify Bill
payers for us
we knew that the the the Medicaid rates
were going to be uh too low we knew that
we had this state
um uh salary increase coming so the
request was please Identify some Bill
payers for us so that this isn't all new
spending and
um and so uh what we ended up going with
is a continuation of what's called a
back of the budget uh general fund
reduction what we do is we ask like we
did in the current term that they force
their spending such that they can lapse
back to us 23.4 million dollars at the
end of the term
23.4 million sounds problematic to a lot
of people but but I don't think it is
it's we it's non-inflation-adjusted it's
the amount that they've got now we wrote
more flexibility into the legislation so
that they can do a better job of
managing funds between accounts
and they they've done the current year
at the 23.4 million that's about 1.1
percent of all of the general funds this
is if you've ever been in the corporate
world you know that at any given budget
year you can be asked to cut 10 percent
across the board so we're just asking
them to manage 1.1 percent uh give back
of what we're budgeting for them
um also we we continue the ceiling of
three thousand on the filled full-time
authorized position that kept us from
having to add
money to the budget that they couldn't
spend probably anyways because the
workforce isn't there so so that back of
the budget uh reduction to me is just
recognizes the reality of the situation
moving on to the office of the
commissioner there's something called
the prescription drug affordability
board if you're in Commerce you've heard
it if you've been if you've been in
division three you've heard about it
what this entity is is uh got initiated
a couple of terms ago and it turned out
that we created the most powerful
autonomous entity in New Hampshire it
has under current law the authority to
tax to regulate and to enforce their
regulation without it really being
responsive or accountable to anyone so
so this is the definition of a poor
government design so we have an
amendment in there that basically says
instead of them being able to Levy taxes
on their own we're going to fund them
with General funds we're going to take a
look at the powers that they were given
to see if there's redundancy in their
efforts and we're going to eliminate the
ability their ability to issue their own
civil fines if they ask a company for
data and the company doesn't provide the
data currently that organization has the
authority to find them up to twenty five
thousand dollars per incident
without any oversight by any other
department
on the next page we allow the health
care facility workplace violence
prevention act to go into effect on
schedule the hiccup here is that when we
establish this act last term there
wasn't a fiscal note attached to it and
then for some reason in the budget
process even though it was law it didn't
ever get budgeted so DHHS came back
asking us to
hold in forbearance their obligation to
expend Manpower on things like rule
making and so rather than suspend the
whole program as requested we just
suspended the obligation of the state to
to do its part and because the private
sector can can handle this actually
better without us I think and they'll
figure that out in the next couple years
with this amendment
um we spend a lot of money on
Information Systems to try to buy I.T
productivity and the big one is the
Medicaid management information system
where we're spending 20.5 million
dollars and that's being met with a 65
million dollar match by the federal
government that's all for operations and
maintenance this is an incredibly
expensive system we it had been in hb2
we moved it into hb1 so for those of you
who are following the knits and the
noise going why is division three asking
for more money than the governor did it
part of the reason is because there are
a couple of these items that were in hp2
that we wanted to put into HP one for
future transparency
a big one big policy issue is we added
uh the granite Advantage Program the
Medicaid expansion program into the
budget and some people have said well
why are you doing that even I mean we
got the Senate bill that that passed I
don't know I think it was 22 to two it
was a landslide whatever it was and it's
coming over to us why don't we just deal
with that bill and not put this into hp2
well we're putting it into hb2 because
currently the federal government is
paying a 90 percent match
a 90 match that that's my that's kind of
money you can't turn down
um but there's no long-term guarantee
that what that match is going to be this
this feels a little like you know the
old heroin dealer giving you your first
couple of hits and then once you get
addicted to it they you know start
charging you so that's a that's that's
kind of an analogy with the federal
government on this so we need to have a
Sunset date so the Sunset date on this
is two years the Senate says that it
should be permanent and so that's
something we're going to debate
there's an extension of postpartum care
for for new moms and babies from 60 days
to 12 months that's what's the clinical
research suggests is the right amount of
time to make sure that women have the
the mental health counseling and the
clinical care beyond the initial two
months post-pregnancy we have a waiver
that 35 other states have have accepted
that basically says for those women and
children who are in the United States
lawfully that those otherwise eligible
women can be able to get expanded care
through the chip program and and other
services
by waving a five-year requirement for
those of you who know the immigration
system generally for legal immigrants we
say that there's a five-year period that
you have to be in the nation before you
can uh are eligible for care or for uh
benefits and so so we waive that for the
health care component here all of this
under the Medicaid we fully funded the
governor's recommended levels
plus some we we we enhanced a little bit
the division of Human Services
we we took representative walner's idea
there is federal money called temporary
assistance to needy families TANF and it
builds up year over year into an account
and we had about 67 million dollars in
it and she had you know two or three
items in here that seemed to be good
Investments to help support
our Workforce Development by allowing
the child care services to hire to so
they have the capacity to reduce wait
lists and then we increase the
eligibility thresholds so that more
people would be eligible the two that
you see there the 85 percent of median
income is essentially the same 300
percent family poverty level that we've
seen in other legislation but we kept it
as a percent of State medium income
because that matches federal law better
same with the next page on the 75th
percentile
we added back into fb1 this is another
reason our house bill one is bigger than
the governors is we took money that for
the sununu center continuing operations
and put it into hb1 so that there would
be transparency and continuity
one of the things we heard that I'm very
proud of division three is we heard for
the very first time that we were still
subjecting
juveniles to a strip search when they
came in and given that we're trying to
obtain a trauma-informed therapeutic
based delivery system in the in that
Health Care setting
saying hello take your clothes off so I
can strip search you is just not a great
way to start that Health Care
consultation so so out of the budget
that they asked for we reduced it by a
couple million dollars over the biennium
and they agreed if we gave them
flexibility on moving money around
within their accounts that they would go
ahead and acquire a full body scanner so
that the so that the strip search is no
longer required I I just think that's
good compassionate reallocation of
scarce resources
the next item under elderly and Adult
Services this is something you should go
talk and brag about to your counties
because this is the continuation of what
we established in the current budget we
added more State money to what's called
a county cap system to where
in Rockingham County I was told because
of the additional money that we provided
the CFO said that that allowed him to
reduce the request for property tax
increases at the county level by seven
percentage points I don't know that's
that's real property tax relief it's
kind of hidden deep in the budget but
you should be aware of it and and be be
glad about it
our support at the state level for
developmental Services is sort of
interesting we're obli we obligated
ourselves by law to fully fund
the DD Community such that
there were no Financial obstacles
to to have a zero wait list
now the problem with having this goes
back to what I was saying earlier you
can throw money at a problem and we have
required by law we fully funded it but
there just isn't the capacity in the
system to actually provide the services
so one of the things that uh that
representative erf did that I thought
was was kind of brilliant is he he
recognized that as we approach the end
of this term we probably had money that
we had previously obligated for the DD
wait list that could not possibly be
spent and so we're taking the amount
that couldn't possibly be spent and
we're moving it into the next year to
reduce the next budget's demands
um
acquired brain disorders got additional
funding at the governor's request these
are pretty substantial
um and I I don't recall the source of
these acquired brain disorder Services I
know I know from my military experience
just being around
explosions and other things can create
brain disorders that need treatment
that's a fairly expensive line item
couple line items and and I I and
because it grows so fast I'm going to
ask in my capacity on Health and Human
Services or excuse me HHS oversight for
us to get periodic reviews on how that
money is being spent we didn't have time
in division three to really drill into
it the way that we could
on the next page 23 go ahead there's a
question somewhere we have a question
why is it that those two line items not
combined it's a duplicate so why isn't
the the you know 92.4 million added in
with the 17.9 and then the percentage
change why is it a duplicate line item
on here
I believe the last one there is is
children versus adults same services but
for children
okay so you just didn't note that all
right I believe that's what happened yes
any other any other questions thank you
so uh thank you uh for the question
thank you one over here representing the
whole
yes
you're in division three are you not I
am I was trying to make an additional
comment relative to the scanners that
you talked about earlier in favor what's
not we didn't know at first it's not
just about coming in the facility it's
every time the child goes in and out of
the facility which was important right
they go to see a parent they go to see
an attorney all of those go through that
same
Right strip search and it's something
that should have been implemented years
ago and it can be relatively easily so
thank you so I I don't know about you
but I I just think uh the scanner made
sense I mean if we can go through one of
these at the airport I mean certainly we
could do this for um
when these kids are incarcerated on page
23 the top of it
[Music]
um
this is funding to fund the New
Hampshire kidney cancer incidents phase
three feasibility study now I'm I'm not
a researcher I don't do pfas research
but what we heard in testimony pretty
clearly is that in order to get to phase
three
would you believe you have to go through
phase one and phase two
and upon completing phase two under
particularly narrow criteria then you go
to phase three which is an in-depth more
more
defining more detailed analysis of
what's going on to correlate the
incidence of pfast to the incidence of
disease so it's extremely rare to go to
phase three and we need to do that in
one of our communities all of our
communities are important but we know
where Merrimack is located and how it's
so close to such a large population
centers or population centers so this is
this is a five hundred thousand dollars
to to learn what we don't yet know about
the correlation between
the things in our environment and
diseases that we're seeing let me
interrupt
this pfast has become such an issue Des
is setting very low standards for all
water treatment systems and I question
them and say based on what
and it's all the studies have been done
on rodents
how about humans
well there hasn't been enough
so finally
we have a population that has been
affected and we're going to do some
human studies and I think it's very
important if we're going to spend
billions on water treatment facilities
without knowing the real effects on
humans so to me this was a landmark
study and so I think it was very
important that we fund it so we can find
out finally what are the real effects on
humans thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um
in the
we're almost at the end here uh the for
the division of Behavioral Health you'll
see that we allocated 7.4 million in
general funds this is above the
governor's request and and in return we
expect 6.6 million in uh matching funds
from the federal government that money
is going into something that we refer to
as a system of care so for those of you
who aren't following along closely if
you reflect back on what I had said
earlier about the ER boarding crisis
that what we also in in addition to
wanting to have capacity for moving
people out of the ERS we want to have
some Community capability that would
intervene and keep it so that you didn't
need to send somebody to the ER to begin
with we refer to those
capabilities those upfront capabilities
in large part as a system of care system
of care is bigger than that but what
this money is intended to do is again to
create capacity so that we have fewer
people requiring
the need to go to the emergency room and
this particular money is targeted at the
capacity for our children
the next bullet down
there's there's a couple things that you
don't see on this sheet but in the
aggregate what we wanted to do was we
wanted to protect the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs so
that we kept a prior legislative promise
to fund them at five percent of alcohol
sales they've been getting less than
five percent and so what we did was we
went ahead and and added another 1.1
million or so somebody did some math on
the projections of the alcohol and we
came up with what the revenue number
ought to be at five percent but then we
did something else and I actually think
this is more important in a way there
were two hb2 items that were put into
hb2 that earmarked and directed the
spending of the commission's money on
particular items and so
so I thought and I and the majority of
division three thought that that was not
transparent enough that we shouldn't be
taking this independent commission with
its own budget process and using it to
so that we could go around the back door
and earmark funds so we so we killed
those two items while protecting the the
revenues and my communication to the
chair of that uh Patrick Tufts is that
uh you know there's there's so many
respected stakeholders on that
commission and they have such good
budget processes if they want to fund
the two things that we pulled out then
they they have mechanisms to do that
without or spending their money for them
we established for the first time that
the request to representative tolerski
some money to go for a local coalition
to help reduce prevent and reduce youth
substance use and although her hometown
is is a key player in ashua there are
five other or there are four other towns
rather that are spreading around New
Hampshire a little bit to give some
geographic distribution of that money
and so there was a request for more than
that but since this was a first time
funding request and there was a some
ambiguity around the existence of
matching money we we we we took a just a
smaller bite at this then we get into
the Veterans Home
the we basically accepted the proposal
we didn't change our proposal other than
to give them a little bit more
flexibility on moving money within their
accounts and they budgeted a census of
225 again their their biggest problem
isn't the money it's the workforce so
that's a consistent theme throughout
this we we I if you ask me what it would
take to fully fund our health care
delivery system in New Hampshire I
couldn't possibly tell you because
there's there's not enough you know
analytical math to figure it all out
given the other variables and the
biggest one is we don't have the the
human capacity in the state to do it so
um so on one hand you want to get the
capacity you want to encourage Your
Capacity with more money on the other
hand you know that there's a point in
reality which more money is not the
solution of the problem and so it just
got to be judgments and and the uh the
the the nine members of division three
to include the chairman when he's able
to sit in we all have our independent
judgments and in this budget recognizes
our best Collective judgment on meeting
the needs for health care in New
Hampshire through the state mechanisms
and with our our ability to Resource it
so I'm happy to take questions if there
are any okay we have a question right in
front there
hi
um I respect all that you do this is all
so new to me I am a freshman and I know
this is an incredible task
but I have to say the one thing that I
need an answer to Is we are spending two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
expand the teacher of the year program
but we are spending two hundred thousand
dollars
for reduced use substance abuse I
understand you have to rob Peter to pay
Paul
I just don't know how to explain that to
my constituents do I say I just don't
know because I wasn't there
but that just kind of slapped me in the
face a little and I apologize if I'm
offending anybody that is not my intent
say again what the 200 000 is your
questioning you were spending 200 000
for a first time funding for local
coalitions to prevent
and reduce youth substance abuse
and we are spending two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to expand the
teacher of the year program
so so I'm not able to compare and
contrast the two programs because I only
dealt with the 200 000 for the
prevention I know I know I'm just saying
I will answer your question to the
extent that I'm I'm able to and the
initial request was 625
000 for the five we reduced it to 200
000 uh for the five that's forty
thousand dollars each uh to me it's
enough to try five different pilot
projects to to find if that money can
stimulate matching money coming out of
the community uh and I and I think in
theory we all have said before that an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure and I agree 100 sure so if we can
get in on the front end and prevent and
and recover these kids particularly uh
it's going to save us a lot of money
down the road I agree 100 percent
this is sort of an experiment there were
there were these five groups that have
asked for help
they've asked for help on what we all
regard as a very serious issue my
question is I don't question what you
did I'm just saying that yes I
understand it's going to slap there's
there's like 11 000 teachers and and
there's also 150 000 students I don't
know maybe 20 000 a high school but we
have to try to experiment and see if
these group groups can make a difference
years ago I remember we were giving a
group uh a million a year to try to cut
down on teenage smoking a year or two
later we said you haven't you haven't
caused any change we're taking the money
away the same thing will happen here
again if these groups do well we will
probably give them more money because
it's a serious problem we all understand
I agree it is a horrendous problem
horrendous problem I'm just saying
it just it I question I I know
somebody's going to say to me so you're
spending two hundred thousand to try to
prevent use from becoming drug addicts
but you're spending 250 000 to expand
to expand the teacher of the year
program
that's going to come to me
from the people that I work for
I just don't know how to answer that and
my answer is going to have to be
I'm going to play dumb I'm a freshman I
understand there's a lot of robbing
Peter to pay Paul but I cannot answer
that question I just want to show you
it's one that stands out to me and it
respectfully because I don't understand
at all chairman Emerick may have some
comments the teacher of the year
expansion to that 250 000 came to
finance in the governor's budget we
questioned it and said so what what are
you going to do I mean
the idea was to take the teacher of the
year as a as a speaker as a trainer
to circulate among teachers
and see if they can help the profile
teachers improve to be like that teacher
part of that is paying the salary of
that teacher while they vacate their job
which if I was the principal of that
school I'd be very upset about right
because you're taking my best teacher
and the best teacher in the state and
send her somewhere else or him but
anyway so it's a budget item
I don't think they can spend 250 000 but
that that's why it's budgeted that way
it's a it's a pilot and I can't tell you
if it's going to work or not thank you
everything we've fund has to deliver or
it won't be in the next budget
I think you're an accident or she okay
over here
I'm not sorry am I next yep thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh I'm Meryl Gibbs
I represent conquered word nine
um and I have a kind of overall question
uh which I tried to hold until the end
of the presentation
um but first I would like to thank the
members of the finance committee for all
of your hard work I know how hard it is
dealing with the budget many years ago I
was director of a small state agency and
I really do know how hard it is to deal
with the budget uh but my question deals
with the interests and dividends tax
um and uh I'll start out by saying that
of course nobody gets pleasure from
paying taxes
um but uh as uh the late Supreme Court
Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes is
reported to have said taxes are the
price we pay for a civilized society
and New Hampshire has lived with the
interest in dividends tax for a very
long time uh it was originally started
in
1923. I actually looked it up on the
Department of Revenue website
and so my question is
um rather than repeal it why not keep it
and invest the money in those places uh
in New Hampshire where the needs are
most urgent and there are many such
places but I'll just mention three of
them which are what I hear
and from what I've been reading places
that have particularly urgent needs
and these are Medicaid
uh
uh second is public schools and I guess
my question is there why not have
Excellence not just adequacy uh and have
Excellence everywhere poor towns as well
as Rich towns and uh the third being
affordable housing so that is a a
general and Broad question so I'm not
sure who I should address it to but I'm
hoping that there's somebody who can
give me a little more information on
that thank you
representative McGuire wants to give it
a try
I'll start with the first half of that
which is about taxes
um
in I think and I think many of us do
that the interest in dividends tax is
the most economically destructive tax we
have to the state
so when you tax something you you get
less of it right and it's it's sometimes
that's deliberate we tax cigarettes we
tax liquor we tax sins because we want
less of them partially and partially we
want the revenue but
um when what the interests and dividends
tax is is its attacks on savings and
investment
and savings and investment is something
that we want to encourage and in fact we
have spending in the budget to encourage
savings and investment we have spending
on affordable housing we have a
Department of Economic Development
things like that so on the one hand
we're discouraging savings and
investment and on the other hand we're
trying to encourage it by spending on it
if you see what I mean so unlike all of
our other taxes this is a direct tax on
the future viability of the New
Hampshire economy savings and investment
Capital formation is what makes tomorrow
better than today it's it's what makes
things grow in the future whereas other
kinds of taxes taxes on consumption are
it means we consume less today right we
have a tax on rooms and meals for
example so that means people go to
restaurants less than they would
otherwise right so that's not a
destructive tax to the Future it's not a
destructive tax to the economy of the
state in the same way so so our argument
is this is an important tax to get rid
of now it's also important just from a
you know a PR sort of point of view in
the sense that we're known as a state
without income tax but there are other
states like Florida Texas Tennessee Etc
that Washington state that we're
competing against for businesses and and
and
people and so we have a little asterisk
by our no income tax and this would get
rid of that asterisk
uh I guess I'd like to ask for a
follow-up question yes
um but the then the obvious next
question is what Revenue are we
replacing it with
what what what Revenue we're replacing
it with yes
it specifically in the governor's budget
um it started out with with eliminating
the communication tax the communication
tax is a tax on telephone calls
right so it's a consumption tax it's
it's uh it brings in roughly 28 to 29
million dollars a year it's slowly
declining because more and more of of
the cost of telephones is data not not
calls and it's a it's a tax on calls not
data so that's it's declining a little
bit over time
but we retain that tax so so compared to
current law this is a net plus for the
state in terms of Revenue over a long
period of time it's a it's a gain in
this particular budget this particular
change is again in this budget of about
40 million dollars I think maybe 25 I
don't remember exactly somewhere between
20 and 40 million dollars it's a hurt to
the next binance budget but it's a gain
from for future budgets after that
future bienniums of roughly 50 plus
million dollars a budget so we we did in
fact
um have less tax cuts if in just in
terms of dollars than than the governor
proposed
how does that compare
um how does retaining the communications
tax uh how does that compare in dollar
amounts to what we would have received
if we retained the interest and
dividends tax
the difference here is we're losing
remember that some years ago we decided
to downsize interest in dividends one
percent a year
so it's it's fading away anyway we've
accelerated its fade so we took out the
two percent the one percent years
because they were bringing in very
little so we're losing 17 million
overall by the way we've structured
the going away of the interest in
dividends tax and so that was going away
anyway we've accelerated its departure
so we still have excellent Revenue we
have record revenue and it's increased
fairly well so by substituting as you
said Communication Service tax that's
about 26 million a year so we have a
game as as you're questioning it's 26
million and one losing 17 million in the
other it comes out fairly well positive
thank you thank you over here
so underneath page 23 under the DHA DHHS
division of Public Health division of
Behavioral Health under the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
um
retaining that five percent gross liquor
profits
so that means like in fiscal year 24 and
25 that's like 22 million
what are they doing with that money what
is that commission doing on Alcohol and
Other Drugs who's being paid those
profits uh what salaries are being paid
do we know all that information
sure
um all the relevant numbers to answer
your question are not in this paragraph
what what this paragraph is saying is
after we meet
long-standing I didn't make the promise
I'm just keeping the promise of five
percent of the alcohol funds go into
this commission it's going to add about
1.1 million dollars so so where you see
11.1 million transfer that's the total
the base was already prepared to be 10
million keeping the promise costs us
another 1.1 million total of 11.1 so
that that those are the numbers to the
to the question about the commission I'm
I'm I'm on that commission and
um what I've witnessed over the year or
so that I've been on it is that there is
a tremendous cross-section of
stakeholders throughout New Hampshire
who are on that from law enforcement to
behavioral Health to members of the
Department of Health and Human Services
to community providers it's just it's a
multi-disciplinary group of stakeholders
they're probably number I don't know 40
or so and they have been in business for
many years now and they have produced
routinely budgets where they take the
alcohol revenues and they allocate it to
various things like I got interested in
how how can we fund some recovery around
the domestic violence problem induced by
alcohol and drug and I was very pleased
to find that they have they already had
three separate programs where they were
funding different kinds of domestic
violence interventions that totaled
something like 600 700 000. so so I
can't tell you the whole thing I can
tell you I think that the the
commissions
budgets are online they are subject in
91a like like any of us and so the their
budgets are publicly accessible
okay it's just everything that's over
ten thousand dollars is supposed to run
through the house and this special
commission which is millions of dollars
is funneling money into areas where we
should be making those decisions I mean
it's just I know this is a huge budget
and there's a lot of things to go
through but being a Freshman as well
these are the types of things that offer
a red flag for me and it should offer a
red flag for
um our constituents so
but thank you so I share the the
representatives uh interest in the
commission and how it's funded and how
it sort of skirts our constitutional
duty to control spending
um but I I it it happened before me it
happened you know or when I was a
freshman you never know what happens
when you're a freshman uh but but
anyways if if it's something you want to
look at in the future I'd be happy to
talk to you about it thank you
next thank you very much
um someone returned to the uh top of the
interesting dividends tax in the
rationale Ford is
I understand is that this will be make
New Hampshire into a magnet for the
nation's High High
um let's say high wealth individuals
that they're all going to be abandoning
Tennessee and Florida and California
other states and they're all going to
race here and we also although we're not
doing anything new to the business taxes
that was also rational for the business
tax that all the entrepreneurs are all
going to want to shut down their
businesses in Massachusetts New York and
all come here my question is uh
one problem that is where are all these
people going to live are they going to
crowd out uh working age families who
are already in New Hampshire and um
and the other thing is uh I did notice
this budget is free of culture War stuff
and is that partially reaction to what's
kind of gone wrong in Tennessee what we
see going on in Tennessee in Florida and
other states where
um
you know their Governors have kind of
Taken on some controversial uh
conference issues which uh
you know which are not necessarily uh
not necessarily liking to everybody
including some of the high wealth
individuals who have moved to those
states to avoid taxes so how do we how
do we do this so how do we invite these
people here while still like uh having
room for uh you know younger people to
live in the state and what plans have we
made from the incredible growth that all
these tax cuts are going to supposedly
cause thanks so so representative
Corrigan uh it's good it's good to see
you back in the house I'm glad you're
doing well yep I was going to ask you if
you had any candy to share with us but I
thought too I thought that was too soon
but um but I'm glad you're I'm glad
you're doing well you you're asking a
very Broad
question and I think we're here today to
talk about budget specifics and you're
you're you're bringing up the
fundamental issues on the distinctions
between at least the two primary parties
in the country right and so rather than
elaborate to let you know that I think
I'm right and you're probably not I I
would I would just say that there hasn't
been a five-year government plan ever
that's really worked well and to the
extent that we have they're able to
enjoy the success of of a society it's
largely delivered by the free market and
so the hope is if we can stimulate you
know the money the movement of money
capital and people into the state uh
localities can figure out the rest and
as you know we're trying to work on the
housing problem okay great thanks and I
I I don't know that we should get into
and there is some housing
debate on the floor here great thanks
next question over here yes Lisa and um
I was interested in the children's
Behavioral Health
now you had referenced that
um I'm just going to step back because
I'm hearing myself you had referenced
the other issue with the emergency room
being filled with people in an
inappropriate way and
is this what's happening to these
children or are there other facilities
for them to go to where that money is
it's a representative I just have to
tell you I have a very hard time hearing
and and so what I what I think you're
asking about is a bullet here on page 23
and I'm just going to tell you I I have
an ear infection so like everything is
reverberating in my head so I'm sorry
for that but I'm just I'm wanting to
know if there are facilities for those
children already in place that aren't in
an emergency room or is this for money
to be put for more beds for that kind of
thing so so by and large we don't have
as much of a facility problem for the
capacity that we're looking to have
prior to somebody being admitted to an
ER we're we're having more of a a human
bandwidth problem where we don't have
the workforce to maximize the capability
of the existing facilities now that's a
very general statement in in specific
areas it's going to be off but as far as
the broad brush I think that's accurate
to be
you know have more
intense treatment
so so if we accept that we have too many
people staying in the emergency rooms
because they don't have a place to be
discharged and there are too many people
in the hospital
ERS because we didn't have adequate care
for them prior to them going to the
emergency room we're trying to solve
both of those problems on the on the on
the front end you know the idea is if
you can get in front of a kid and start
to provide them with the behavioral
health counseling and support and yes
sometimes some medication you can keep
them out of the ER to begin with so that
that's that's basically sort of the you
know the clinical objective of much of
this on the front end is to provide them
the treatment so that they don't end up
in the ER to begin with
so that's more like Staffing getting
Staffing Staffing is our biggest problem
I mean money and Staffing those are the
two big things
yeah thank you
next
representative owes
representative Bose this is a general
budget question
in 2021 the tax Foundation ranked New
Hampshire 47th in the nation in per
capita spending
for taxes at 2 313 dollars per person
how will the
12.7 percent increase in this budget
affect our ranking and our per capita
spending for taxes in the state
until we know all the other states we
don't know where we stand I suspect
they'll all have to go up just to keep
people working because like we've seen
I think the major problem we heard from
all the people that testified before us
we can't get Staffing why can't we get
Staffing because they can make more
money somewhere else if we can't be
competitive in the wages we're still
going to have Staffing problems and I
suspect it's it's Nationwide so when we
see what other states do then we'll get
an idea we we still have some very good
ranking among all the states and I don't
expect that we'll change all that much
next question
thank you Mr chairman a question
directly to representative Edwards
specific to page 22 and the
developmental services
funding within that funding if you would
clarify the following or answer the
following question the developmental
Services wait list
is
do I understand that's within that 830
832 million
yes and to follow up on that is in
meeting the current uh census of where
these funding numbers will come from
will this allow for rate hourly rate
increases because that's the biggest as
related to other subject matter it's
already discussed that we are not
finding enough people to do the job in
the home and community-based care
because the rate of hourly rate is not
enough of an incentive for folks to take
on these jobs is that allowed within
your discussions and the funding that
was hereby presented
no but um when we did the targeted
Medicaid reimbursement rate hikes we we
allocated funding on an algorithmic
basis
to where uh we funded 20 different lines
of Provider Services all in an effort to
continue to build capacity this this
these line items are specialized efforts
to do that also with more money chasing
somewhat limited Workforce with the
hopes that it'll stimulate people from
Massachusetts to work here or people
that live in New Hampshire working in
Massachusetts to stay and work here so
it's
okay one more follow-up Mr chairman sure
I just don't know who the authority of
in jurisdiction is here I want to make
sure I do it right uh the the issue was
on the then the hourly rate and what was
the challenge in the last uh
two terms was that we had a cap of
fifteen dollars per thousand if not per
thousand per hour is we need to get
closer to 20. for this these issues to
be filled and it was that part of the
discussion
there's two parts of the problem as the
chairman was pointing out one is the
rates that you're discussing the other
is the need the line item you're talking
about is the need the rates are in the
Medicaid rate setting this particular
all three of these bullets in this
particular area require by law
that they be budgeted for at the full
need
regardless of whether that need can be
met so these numbers that are in here
have to be there based on the need
whether that whether whether that need
can be met or not be met if we can't
change on the funding with these funds
where we changed around the funding was
on the Medicaid rate setting side where
hopefully that will increase our
capacity to address more of the need
does that make sense
so so uh no as usual
um now unfortunately it's the law you
know we're stuck with that no no without
respect sir I'm very familiar with the
law being here 20 years but the key is
whether the rate of pay does not have a
false cap and that it can respond to the
market so that these families can have
these Services provided in the home yes
you understand that and you but what
you're missing is that that's why we
worked on increasing the Medicaid rates
right right to increase the capacity but
by law this part of the budget there's
two parts of the budget this part has to
be
set based on current rates and the need
regardless of the ability to fulfill the
need over the biennium
okay I'll stipulate to that I do
understand that it's are we meeting the
challenge and I don't that's what I'm
concerned about that's why I asked the
question fair enough but we gotta if you
want if these funds want to be used for
another purpose you have to change the
law that's the bottom line these
particular line items
okay thank you
all right I appreciate your patience
while we go through all these fine
points on the budget I want to I don't
want to waste the extra dollars we spent
on color
for these items that we spend for the
big picture and while we're talking the
other legislative budget assistants who
have assisted in all the divisions I
want to point to the chief legislative
budget assistant overall it sees this
and that's Mr Michael Kane who is the
elected legislative budget assistant
and back here by the doors his number
two
Chris
I'm going to say the wrong last name I
don't know why
Chris Shea
done that before
so
page page two you'll see where we're
going to spend the general funds
throughout the budget
and then someone who's very sharp will
question
compared with page five
one says
3.975 billion the other one says
3.732.7 million or 3 billion why is
there a difference
the difference is
page two is spending a little bit of
surplus from 2023
page five is showing what we're taking
in by Ways and Means estimates from
2024 and 2025
so that is
less money because it doesn't have the
Surplus included in it that's what we
collect
and just also page three
is
where the money goes out total funds so
that includes not just general funds
which is just one small part but all the
total funds
and the page below that again page four
that's where the Appropriations come in
from all the funds and you'll see there
the page four the big blue piece federal
funds that's a pretty good piece 32
percent so finally we're getting back a
little of our
income tax we don't get back as much as
most States but we get back something so
all so those those things are very
illustrative in my mind I always ask LBA
since I first got on this committee put
them in pie charts I'll understand them
better
so those those are all very good things
to look at as well as when you go to
pages of 24 through 35 where you see a
lot of spreadsheets and these are also
important in getting an overall
understanding of the budget
the
page 24 shows the combined
statement of general and education trust
funds and some of the some of the places
they're collected and spent and you go
to page 25
and you see the statement for just the
general funds so that's a whole
different thing as I say when you
realize the general funds are only one
small part of the total spending
then Paige page 26 we start to look at
schedule one which kind of breaks it
down a little more into where the money
is coming in specifically
and schedule two
shows the general fund
distributions across government and
where some of them are going by various
bills like Senate bill Senate bill one
and HB 384 HP 504
some of the where those monies are being
spent schedule two goes on for a few
pages
and then the education trust fund has
its own three pages so you can see where
the education trust fund money monies
are going
uh and you'll see that we're not
shorting anybody
but
these are a very good
items for understanding
and then the last page 35 is is the Aid
by category where that's going out and
all the different
uh
types of funds some of it's going into
Highway fund and so on so
I hope this has helped it's very
complicated and an old expression we
used in the military it's like you're
drinking from a fire hose most of it's
going by you and maybe you'll remember
some of it later but
any one of us would be willing to sit
down and explain any parts of this that
we don't have time to do right now but I
appreciate your attendance appreciate
your your ability to learn all this
about
the state budget it's the most
complicated Bill we have and it's the
most important vote that you'll cast and
as I said not everything in here pleases
everybody not even me certainly not the
governor because we've made changes that
he will probably be upset about
but
you have to remember this is the place
where the budget is made no other place
I appreciated having a couple of
senators here to listen and they've left
now but obviously if there are things
that we look at
Thursday and said aha there's a new
Amendment what should we have done about
it
there's another chance take it to the
Senate
they will listen and maybe it's such a
great idea you can convince 14 of them
ways you might not have been able to
convince
200 people here so there's another
chance
at the at the budget when we go to the
Senate they'll be kind of speeding it up
but they will be using a lot of what
we've done they always have in the past
and make some little changes to them to
their own one of the things that
concerns us all as I said this is
unprecedented both for the for the
amount of of
of inflation we have to deal with the
amount of jobs that we can't fill those
are unprecedented we've never heard so
much about those as we've had this year
what's going to go happen going forward
usually the Senate sees
the the budget the uh the revenue from
April and May
that we don't get to see
and quite often it's higher those are
some of the biggest months if you're on
ways and means you understand that April
and May big months business taxes come
in big time and everybody's paying their
federal income taxes at the same time
putting aside their state income taxes
business income business Enterprise tax
and business profit Stacks so quite
often they can sit there and have more
money to spend than we do and they
usually lot it over us for me go to the
committee of conference you didn't fund
this properly but anyway I don't know
what will happen going forward
people keep predicting recession
will we start to see it in April May I
hope not but we may see it in 24 and 25
so I don't want to spend everything that
we hope goes to the rainy day fund
because it may be coming it may be
coming in the next budget we may have a
problem so we don't want to listen to
amendments they're saying oh you're
putting money in the rainy day fund we
should put it here
I don't know how rainy it's going to be
in 20
6 and 27
and I hope it is isn't as bad as some
have predicted but let's keep that in
mind when people want to say why are you
putting money in the rainy day fund I
want to put in my project
please be with me we may need to plan a
little further into the future than the
next two years so I appreciate the fact
that we're all here we're willing to
answer any of your questions take me
aside whenever you catch me and I'll
have this I'll carry this around with me
call me on the phone if you want any of
us that are close to you and we'll do
our best to try to reason it out it's
difficult
having all these things in the air as
I've said before
sometimes we find something it seems
like a lot of money two years from now
we'll look back and say hey what'd you
do with that money
and we also sometimes call for audits
from the legislative budget assistant
also has a whole other group that do
Audits and I like to look at those
Audits and see so how did it all work
out
and if I find out that the money wasn't
well spent or maybe it wasn't even spent
then we can pull it back
last year's budget was was balanced
because we found
hundreds of employees in
Health and Human Services that never got
hired money was there but they didn't
hire him they couldn't hire him whatever
reason I don't even think they had the
office space for them but that helped us
balance the budget so we follow up on
all the money we hand out how is it
spent what were the results did it work
please be with us anything you find out
come and tell us we're always happy to
hear whatever you hear out there in the
Hinterlands seeing all your your
your constituents and some of them might
be state employees who will be willing
to share with you something that they
would be afraid to say
in their office so we're always looking
for those little tidbits and I
appreciate your attention and thank you
very much and I think if representative
Osborne may be here to take over
for a caucus is he still here
oh
all right
so I believe there'll be a republican
caucus so I think we have a few
Democrats that are probably going to
depart but I appreciate that being here
to listen to the budget presentation
and
finding out all you can it's a very
complicated thing I'm still learning
thank you all for your attendance